hey guys my name is Jess it is the
fourth of April and here's the things
that mattered in gaming today Ubisoft
have confirmed that a major
game-breaking bug which locks players
out of the division will be fixed in the
April 12 update the bug in question
occurs after crafting a high-end
backpack and stops players from logging
back into the game at a later time
Ubisoft have said we will be deploying a
fix in update 1.1 on April 12 that
should resolve instances of the infinite
loading / backpack issue due to this fix
requiring a client patch we cannot
deploy it at an earlier date we thank
you for your patience the April update
is also set to introduce the game's
first raid style incursion mission
called Falcon last and will introduce
new gear that can give bonuses when
equipped as a set more details about the
upcoming resident able to remake have
come to light thanks to a new interview
producer yoshiaki hirabayashi told
videogamer that his goal is to recapture
the spirit of the original game he
explains the Resident Evil game cube
remake was my first project at capcom i
was able to learn from more experienced
colleagues and see with my own eyes how
they translated their efforts into such
a masterpiece that built on an already
well-received game it was an incredibly
valuable experience for me as for the
remake he said that the team has gone
over every single feature of Resident
Evil 2 with a quote flying toothcomb
approach from the audiovisual asset to
the game's pacing finally uncharted 4
director Neil druckmann has said the
game's ending will be divisive given the
response so far from test groups he told
IGN there will be some arguments about
the ending I'm excited indifference
would be the worst thing I would rather
have people hate it than be indifferent
to it we'll see how they react elsewhere
in the interview you said that a thief
and will be what you'd expect from
Naughty Dog explaining any time you try
to place something outside yourself it
can easily
of asphalt whenever we make something
that's honest to us that is the game we
truly want to play you know whether you
succeed or not let me know down in that
comment section if you think Nathan
Drake is going to die at the end of
uncharted 4 thirds naughty dog won't
tell us anyway you can add to gamespot
we've got stories on quantum break
achievements and our Dark Souls 3 review
that is it for me today let me know what
you cared about and I will see you again
tomorrow